hey guys thanks tuning in just a quick
one today
I'm going to speak to you about stomach
vacuums and vacuums which work the
transverse abdominal and this is the
muscle that many people forget about
when they're training their abs but it's
actually instrumental in a giving you a
flat stomach be eliminating back pain
for a lot of people and see evening with
your corrector breathing which has many
other positive effects so let's look at
that in a bit more detail so basically
your apps your midsection your core are
made up of many muscle there's not just
apps these are the six muscles this is
the rectus abdominis which is one sheet
of muscle running across the front of
your stomach at the sites you have
internal and external obliques which go
underneath your ribcage barish they're
useful for twisting your body that way
and bending side-to-side the rectus
abdominis are useful for bending
forwards which is why crunching works
them if it wasn't for these the muscles
in your back so just the erector spin in
which Benji backwards indeed snap in
half that's why the best our exercises
which we're going to look at in another
video are ones that don't just involve
doing this short which is a very small
range of movement crunch - you both
bending further back or moving your legs
more than myotatic crunch for instance
so those are some muscles in your core
but another really important one is the
transverse abdominis and what this is is
this muscle wraps around your apps and
is used for squeezing in for bringing
your apps in towards your back so
between the transverse abdominus the
obliques and the erector spinae which
are useful for bending upwards the
opposite of the rectus abdominis or when
you're doing deadlifts these make up
nature's weight belt which has the
combined effect of pulling your stomach
in making the flatter which is obviously
what a lot of people won but also at the
same time supporting your back and this
is one of the reasons that training
these muscles can have
to prevent low back pain gives you a
kind of rigid armor around this area and
it's also very important for plugging Li
energy leaks in the kinetic chain when
you're doing exercises like the press up
it will make you more powerful better
performance fewer injuries it's just you
need to train all the muscles around
there but doing just crunches is not
going to target transfer cells don't lie
you need to use different exercise
system to target lace plank will do it
to an extent but not hugely so actually
the very best way to train it is just to
to use it but bringing in your stomach
like so when you do this and bring your
navel your belly button in towards your
spine that is you working your
transverse abdominals you can do this
exercise anywhere and that's a vacuum to
do a proper vacuum this is what body
goes would use in the Golden Age of
bodybuilding you breathe out pull up
your your diaphragm put your stomach in
using the transverse abdominis and that
they have an ad vacuum stomach vacuum
which you know they've used for posing
but it's actually also a very good way
of trading that muscle giving yourself
the flatter abs so the combination of
the rectus abdominis giving you the nice
six-pack which is just one sheet muscle
divided into six little segments
combined with the transverse abdominis
inside you can't see it but it it pulls
your gut into gives you that flat
stomach will give you much better core
much better looking out I'm working on
my own amendment and I have noticed big
improvements so so you want to use those
sorts of exercises the the vacuums and
if you work those into your program you
should notice some improvements there's
other ways you can do it to make one's
called the catwalk
exercise which is one way Donal force
and then just repeat that movement
bringing your navel in towards your
spine and then releasing it and if you
repeat that whilst in this kind of all
fours position that's the cap on
exercises Tim Ferriss calls it and again
he even man he's mountain in conjunction
with the mastic crunching he says
a way of building good-looking core and
I have to say I don't agree with it you
can also I actually use it
whilst in plank you can do a plank and
then bring that in but also I'd like to
just do it whilst I'm doing other
exercises like what I'm doing the press
ups or the hands down press ups I make
sure that I'm consciously tensing this
part of my body bringing in in order to
give myself a really rigid you know so
again there's no engine no energy links
I'm not swinging around wobbling all
over the place and my form is much
better so that's that's very useful
that's another way you can use it now
something I have heard about regularly
is the idea of tying a piece of string
around your stomach whilst you've got a
slight vacuum on and the idea behind
this is every time you breathe out or
you feel it push there so you're holding
it anymore now some people say you can
use this technique all day whilst you're
at work or to give to your routine etc
obviously not using something quite as
noticeable of this may be the small
piece of string you can keep it on and
throughout the day you'll be forced to
engage the transverse abdominal and by
the end of the day you'll be tired by
the end of the month you'll have slimmer
waistline flatter abs that's the idea I
think I don't personally recommend it
because it knots to breathe properly
they're supposed to breathe from your
stomach it's basically by pushing the
stomach out you breathe in
by letting your stomach out so what this
does is it allows the diaphragm to relax
moving into the abdominal cavity and you
actually engage the lower portion of
your lungs and apparently this can make
breathing 13% more effective more
efficient so you're taking a 13% more
oxygen and as a result you see lower
cortisol levels which will make you feel
less stress and in turn increase your
testosterone in great form in your
anabolic
it will also reduce hypertension make
you more relaxed in your muscles and in
general it's got tons of health benefits
it's far more efficient for running it
will help me to run further faster
improving your being to Matt's
butt so you know having this tight
around the waist was couldn't force you
to do is like not be able to breathe
very well and the thing is most of us or
any breathing correctly we breathe
through our chests when we should be
breathing through our stomachs if you've
got baby they move through their
stomachs most ask me for that chest why
because we sits office desks a lot of
the time or sit in the car on the train
on the commute and when we do this our
body is collapsed that makes it very
difficult for us to breathe properly
we're not supposed to sit down in that
position as much as we do so to
compensate me for my chest and this
becomes habit and so when you stopped
making normally this you can fix that by
focusing on your breathing but planning
consumed right around your stomach is
gonna help of that so I don't think
that's a terrible technique I say maybe
try using it Cajun than during the
workout when you're trying to remind
yourself to engage your core your
exercises maybe try it for a little bit
maybe you just want to just bored and
one positive is it does force you to sit
up straighter which is another important
thing kostya actually makes a big
difference to us
I put the pins between my house when I'm
stood up straight versus slum okay
hopefully illustrating my point but yes
so you don't type piece of string -
they're like all day I think that's
madness but interestingly if he do
please properly and then we service an
isometric or it's just a text there's no
range of movement you're not gonna make
much difference by just holding in but
on the other hand if you move quickly so
you're letting stomach out when you
breathe in like that then you actually
pull your transverse abdominis in in
order to breathe back out you release it
breathe in and you pull it in to read
out you should also be engaging their
chest and you'll run into intercostal
muscles which are the ones in between
your ribs but that one's second as the
second part of a breathing relation you
start a new stomach
and then expand up to your chest rather
than the other way round rather than not
using your stomach at all
say can't remember saying point is that
if you're breathing out and then
breathing in using your stomach then
you're actually exercising that muscle
it's not getting the attention that we
deserved every time you put it back in
your game it's like tension on it and
you're working it so ideal really will
not only improve your mood it will not
only improve your sleep you might
improve your running endurance and your
and all these different things it will
only improve your hormone balance but it
will also give you a small workout on
the transverse abdominal which you can
then further enhance with your workouts
where you're engaging it using things
like the cat vomit exercise so there you
go and you'll see all-around benefits by
paying attention to your breathing and
this muscle of course you've got to work
all the muscles in your core and it's
also just as important to make sure
you're doing exercise your back we have
a tendency the way we train is it has no
bearing on the way we move most of us
will want to train their muscles on the
front of our body our biceps our pets
our ass and we don't care about the back
so you end up that's another reason you
end up by this that in your office job
so you want to make sure you're training
your whole core and I've put a link in
the description to my website to an
article called AB Anatomy very good and
that'll talk you through each of the
muscles in your core and your lower
spine say how to work all of them and
even your hips hip flexors and extensors
and your adductors and abductors they
all play a role in stabilizing this
whole area of making it the way it
should be
I'm learning all this stuff right now
I'm diving deep into it and then take me
into my training hopefully you can
already see that it has some benefits
for me that I'll be continuing my
neighbor over the course of my videos
and I'm going to share all this
information with you healing on my site
so if you like what you've seen today
and found it useful then please
subscribe share like etc and I hope to
see you for the next video thanks for
watching and bye bye